as our monologue continues tonight much
to get to we need to address what is the
revolting repulsive sadly predictable
behavior from two groups of people in
this country yep the same too
predictable groups the mob and the media
the Democratic Party while the vast
majority of our fellow Americans a
working night and day day and night
together to beat back this national
emergency and pandemic these two hateful
groups using what is a disease and a
virus and an important moment to save
lives as a political weapon the dog
bites the beast things if you're feeling
sad let's lash out at Donald Trump
tonight's example comes from the
Democratic Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi now she just authored what is
nothing short of a bizarre rage-filled
Trump obsessive well rant that is full
of love lies outright lies on ending
hypocrisy breathtaking out of touch
reality from her part and according to
the speaker after an Easter weekend full
of deep prayer and reflection I usually
set you up for okay what's next God
apparently communicated to her that
Donald Trump was responsible for the
carnage caused by coronavirus writing
quote in January Donald Trump was warned
about this pandemic ignored those
warnings took insufficient action caused
unnecessary death and disaster okay
let's let truth get in the way of her a
little narrative because he got to
remember China didn't identify the
corona virus until January 9th the first
known case in the United States was
January 21st and ten days later in
record time controversial at the moment
stereo xenophobic fear-mongering racist
January 31st ten days after the first
case in the US Donald Trump implemented
the travel ban then remember mandatory
quarantine first time in over 50 years
subsequent travel bans declared a public
health emergency as a matter of fact
nobody in the history of modern medicine
intersecting with politics has ever
acted faster what was Nancy Pelosi doing
in January that's right spending every
waking moment impeach
the president and then on January 15
five days after the world was warned
about kovat 19 she was all smiles she
signed off on her impeachment ship show
stunt with commemorative pens and smiles
and selfies and pictures she knew the
impeachment witch hunt was dead on
arrival in the Senate yet all of January
into February that is what the focus of
her attention was on nothing about covin
19 in early february as the president
mentioned coronavirus in the State of
the Union remember this scene Pelosi
acting bizarre pre ripping the speech
while the president was talking all
about in some cases coronavirus oh this
was all her pre-planned public
made-for-tv temper tantrum sideshow and
then on February 24th that's a month
after Donald Trump's travel ban well
into this health emergency Pelosi she
shows up for a publicity stunt on the
crowded streets of San Francisco's
Chinatown she's hugging and shaking
hands with supporters and encouraging
everyone to come to Chinatown saying
everything is fine safe here it turns
out it was Pelosi who was giving out
false information
it was Pelosi ignoring the warnings it
was Pelosi who failed to take action
it was Pelosi who failed to lead and it
was Pelosi who was so obsessed with
impeachment and her stunt at the State
of the Union she couldn't see the forest
through the trees and what could easily
be a moment of self-reflection at the
end of Pelosi's prayers and a ranch he
writes quote a weak person a poor leader
takes no responsibility a weak person
blames others Pelosi you are that weak
person you are that poor leader you are
the reason Americans hate career
politicians like yourself even in the
middle of a national emergency pandemic
Pelosi is putting politics just like
every other Democrat before anything
else sick disgusting and by the way the
country and our constituents certainly
deserve better here with more